This hyperbola will be centered at 0, 5 give, it will have an a value of 8, and
a b value of 4. Good thinking if you got these three right. We'll start by
dividing each of these terms by 64. When we divide this term by 64, we'll
simplify it by 1 16th. This term divided by 64 turns into negative x squared
divided by 64. And finally, 64 divided by 64, equals 1. Our y squared term
comes first, which means that our hyperbola needs to open up, an it needs to
open down. There's no number next to the x variable, so that means the center,
or the x coordinate of the center, is 0. The y coordinate of the center would
be positive 5. This is the k it is always next to y. The a is the number that
we move in the x direction so that's underneath the the x squared term. It's
the square root of this number. Since the square root of 64 equals 8, we know
the value of a, it must be 8. For the value of b, we simply take the square
root of 16 which equals 4. We start by graphing the ellipse with a center at 0,
5 and then we move 8 units in the x direction for 2 points. And four units in
the y direction for two more points. Next we draw our dash rectangle around our
ellipse. Then we draw in the two diagonals. And since we know the y squared
term is first and is positive, we know our hyperbola opens up and it opens
down. So we cut our ellipse horizontally. And we flip over these two pieces.
Ultimately, this produces our hyperbola. As a quick check, we can make sure
that these two points are four units vertically away from the center. Our
center is at 0, 5, so yes, this point is four units away vertically, and this
point is four units away in the other direction.